so we're about so we guy now we're just
going to put this in where we have all
the other grenades and explosive we have
found here
these are 81-millimeter mortar grenades
some of these are very dangerous like
this one it has been fired from a motor
but it didn't explode so this one is
probably the most dangerous of all of
these Leo's expeditious at madam chatter
speeds the own centromeres is not
programs Casas I states a Tokarev
irritation was way way WAY kodkod Oh
Kakashi pharmacy sparboe Ducato Nadel
vienna crazy
talus esmad is on a quest the 52 year
old farmer wants to recover the remains
of every forgotten World War 2 soldier
in Latvia want walk at the academy you
can see public Cusco is local some cool
cop 3 its allies missed when you methods
the cows must to do this talus helped
found the gender an NGO whose members
spend their weekends recovering the dead
we there ye up sesh is simply no Sasha
seem till it stalks towards Katerina
in Latvia if you have dead soldiers
buried in your garden down in your
basement inside your walls you call
Tallis since it started in 1999 legenda
has recovered over 10,000 soldiers
Latvia was always between several big
empires Russia Germany Sweden Poland all
wars went through Latvia in second world
war soldiers were not so carefully
buried many of them were still lost on
battlefields left in trenches local
people they came back to their homes
after battles they decided they need to
have at least some burial place those
bodies in a crater fill it with a ground
and that's all Andrus lela's is a 22
year old student a lover of conflict
history who also sells memorabilia
online I'm selling since I'm 16 years
old
I collect mostly German dog tags but I
sell everything from World War one and
World War two in the last five years the
online trade in world war ii memorabilia
particularly nazi relics has exploded in
latvia the global Nazi memorabilia
market is estimated to be worth between
fifty and a hundred million dollars and
thanks to the internet anyone with a
metal detector and a shovel can become a
seller on the most popular for sure
German helmets they can go for few
dollars still few thousand dollars
depends on a helmet German helmet
brother bad condition
but all the leather is still inside
legenda costs around 20,000 euros a year
to run and most of the funding comes
from the members themselves so you might
think that it would be tempting to sell
some of the items the members find on
their digs now I I have never attempted
to take anything from a dead soldier
because the grave for me this sacred
place and those things which the soldier
held in his grave are the last things
which he took with himself
those those need to be with him forever
and Andrus isn't the only member who
thinks of legendas work as sacred Victor
ducks one of legendas co-founders is
another lifelong lover of relics and
memorabilia barcaro is sock interstate s
that Columbia is missing to God but the
satirist this was like Toto Isis inter
salesmen SD Guatavita Baldoni
guru Kasia guys patron she's like [ __ ]
granite as beer Sid Bream supposed to be
used
bloody build out the car Miller
archeology hobbies dissipation but
Caribbean Malaysian Tessa [ __ ] out
stalks the circle cos øx dark Missy PNR
combs called cos dem Cadiz part allies
know she's devious - ectopic we're on
Vienna ops crust estado parcel on each
part sell Coco Puffs - apostle no
a Samana meadow - talk a diamond me see
of madam the remains that legenda finds
are placed in bags and taken back to
Tallis's farm his barn is full of old
rusted helmets shells
rifles and small black cardboard coffins
stacked waiting for identification and
burial
any soldier need to have his name - how
decent gray we do that we we recover
them we give them decent gray and we try
to find the relatives and inform them
where they load one is lying in the
moment
every few months the gender buries the
soldiers it finds over 70 years after
they died fighting 107 Russian soldiers
are finally being laid to rest we don't
separate them or like one is enemy or
another his friend they both died both
soldiers who fought from from any side
they both died and as they are dead they
are not soldiers anymore they are
victims of a war
zenyk rocks toes taya Brede katas any
exact our Tea Room all the Charlie
Drouet Ram gala Christo sad story mode
re tick mark o'mara Nobu swatters girls
by rock never raise the such as Emma
cracks toes
as large static sputtered a system
reading kinetics at rest by the mascara
which but as duo marketers Neville's
managed Eva's mooseville PES - Yves tres
Quatro career Desmond Tutu's career own
taka Montes logs gazania Kamiya Pollux
cocoon where's Noah
you